[Music]
this whole time you've said that you are
here because you're trying to find a
wife I know what you did and I don't
know how you could do that and I just
really don't understand but I really
hope you found what you're looking for I
think I think that'll play out in the
weeks to come you know you don't need to
answer me but I needed to say it that's
contestant Caroline confronting re lyin
die jr. in a shocking moment about his
season ending the show has promised the
finale will be unlike anything fans have
ever seen on The Bachelor et was there
for the women tell all taping and talked
to Caroline backstage she knows what
happens in the end even though fans have
yet to find out why was it important for
you to say that it felt good I'm sorry I
don't know if I can say that but you can
bleep that out right it felt good to get
to say that and kind of get it off my
chest I'm close to the remaining girls
and I mean everything's gonna play out
you'll see you'll see you guys will see
you'll see all of it and you'll see
everything and you will understand why I
felt like I needed to say what I had to
say they tune people stay tuned
[Music]